water the source of life is now a threat
to it in El toul in Rebel held
Northwestern Syria
Monday's earthquake damaged the Afrin
Dam creating a crack that sent its
Waters gashing and flooding a nearby
Village when you've enjoyed war and an
earthquake wading through flood waters
is a bit of cherry on a cake soaked in
Misery
we survived the earthquake but we are
displaced my family was living in a tent
but then the flooding started now I
don't know what will happen to them
the water submerged houses swamped
streets and engulfed fields
the false Tranquility barely conceals
the horror which forced an evacuation
the engineer comes to check the building
and we discover
hundreds of buildings cannot be saved
anymore so they we they ask the people
to empty everything from the building
quickly the worry doesn't stop at the
Syrian border you see there may not have
been any breaches in the dams here in
Turkey but the earthquake hit Zone here
that hosts around 75 percent of the
country's dams that's enough to send
officials scrambling officials say
they're checking around 140 dams and
reservoirs in the south and east of
turkey like this one sehan in Adana
sayhan hasn't been affected but others
have
we have examined 120 of these dams and
reservoirs we found cracks in six dams
however we can safely say these cracks
do not pose any danger
but those assurances haven't eased all
the concerns not only about the safety
of dams but also about other critical
facilities connected to them the thing
is we don't know it yet
and there are eight times actually in
the earthquake area there is a power
plant over there it is a army power
plant in
ocean
so it is very important as well for
turkey it is a main energy it's one of
the main energy sources for electricity
we don't know it is position and what
happened to it is if there is any severe
damage or not
dams in the south and east provide at
least 65 percent of turkia's electricity
many communities live along the rivers
which feed those dams but officials say
their biggest fear so far is what dam
breaches and potential collapses across
the border in Syria will mean for
villages here in turkia Dam's main peed
Rivers but not the flow of catastrophes
Sami zaidan Adana turkia